Barnum & Bailey would have undoubtedly
been proud there may not have been
elephants though or jugglers or trapeze
artists flying through the air
but for hours and hours and hours today
former FBI investigator Peter struck was
walking a tightrope that Republicans
desperately tried to knock him off of
you're asking us to believe that when
you say things like eff Trump and stop
Trump and impeach Trump that those are
just personal beliefs
and that when you say those things you
never cross that line sir I'm asking you
to believe and I'm offering you evidence
you have under oath been as clear as a
bell on that how many interviews did you
conduct related to the alleged collusion
between Russia and the Trump campaign
the special counsels equities has
instructed me not to answer questions
about the ongoing investigation asking
did you know that he was meeting with
representatives from fusion including
Glenn Simpson I cannot discuss the
content of the the operational matters
and your testimony is Bob Mahler did not
kick you off because of the content of
your text it is not my understanding
that he kicked me off because of any
bias I don't appreciate what was
originally said being changed I don't
give a damn what you appreciate agent
struck we get kicked off for having bad
breath I mean it's ridiculous meanwhile
of course we saw Democrats stretching
out the nets to save struck at every
turn using explosive denunciations and
every lame parliamentary trick in the
book stirs truck you are under subpoena
and are required to answer the question
are you objecting to the question if so
please state your objections the
Chairman I object the gentlemen it does
not have standing to object there is no
order no point of order here the the
point of order should be heard I move to
subpoena Steve Bannon in our house
intelligence investigation the motion
has to be heard immediately mr. chairman
motion is not germane I move to overrule
the ruling of the chair motion had made
a table I hate a pepto-bismol that was
very
very dramatic but well that tactic got
old though Democrats just tried to
change the subject altogether there are
3000 children separated from their moms
and dads and the government doesn't know
where their moms and dads are that seems
like something the Judiciary Committee
should be investigating what we have not
done is investigated the children being
stolen away from their families nor have
we looked at our president meeting with
mr. Putin mr. Strock you know you are
before this committee for one reason to
serve as a monumental distraction they
need to identify a villain mr. struck
tag you're it no you're it oh these
games hijinks games circus stay with me
here because there were moments when the
hearing went from circus light to a
complete sideshow and I've talked to FBI
agents around the country you've
embarrassed them you've embarrassed
yourself and I can't help but wonder
when I see you looking there with a
little smirk how many times did you look
so innocent into your wife's eyes and
lied to her about me mr. chairman it's
outrageous well I understand the
passions are running high but I have a
question here what did that accomplish
exactly now at some point the
obfuscation and the hyperbole on both
sides tend to cancel each other out and
most Americans watching the House
Oversight proceedings for any length of
time today probably thought to
themselves
is this really what it's come to at
times it seemed they were more like
contestants and in both parties and they
were competing for the sound bite of the
day I never prejudged anything not in
this case not in any others in second
for what agent struck you mentioned they
were used to the word impeachment that
was used in the context of my not
knowing what this would lead to strategy
now if there are two people that are
thrilled and excited today there are two
people the folks over at Fox News and at
the
wehmanen I have never seen my colleague
so out of control if I could give you a
Purple Heart I would you deserve one all
the veterans must have felt really good
about that little line that didn't work
but so all that aside for just a moment
and we're still at the same point
basically we've been at almost for the
past year so the FBI agent in charge of
two of the most important political
investigations that past decade was
steeped in animus toward candidate and
then President Trump at a time when he
was supposedly impartially examining and
overseeing the Clinton email
investigation he was pretty much
actively rooting for her election
victory he agonized and you read it the
text messages about the possibility that
Trump would win and he assured his then
lover that he would not let that happen
but pay no attention to that because
there's no bias there there is no act of
bias so this false assertion that you're
making that political personal belief
must equal bias that somehow we've
merged those two words together in the
dictionary is one of the triumphs of
what's been going on recently that I
cannot disagree with more is that I and
the other men and women of the FBI every
day take our personal beliefs and set
those aside in vigorous pursuit of the
truth wherever it lies whatever it is I
have a question so the madam of the FBI
who run really high-profile
investigations do they really carry on a
running commentary via text message
about the subject of their
investigations and what they hope
happens to the key players therein I
don't think so
and I certainly hope not but that is
precisely what struck did now there is
no doubt of course as was repeated over
and over again today that FBI agents are
like everybody else they are entitled to
their own political opinions and they
have them but the blatant biases
revealed instructs text and the
specificity therein how we discuss them
with his girlfriend are troubling and
they remain so he claims to take great
offense and he was sitting up very
straight looking down as knows everybody
at the thought that anyone should
believe from his own right
things that he meant to stop Trump
selection and create that insurance
policy that he referenced to guarantee
Trump's defeat but that is what he wrote
and he wrote it as he said today when he
thought nobody was looking but his
girlfriend strux continuing denials of
bias are as incredible and maddening as
today's hearing and that's the angle